[music]
Uh, I'm Helena Chow, managing director,
head of venture capital and crossover
coverage at Bank of America, and I'm
delighted to be here today with Path
Robotics CEO Andrew Lonsbury.
>> Hey, morning everybody.
>> Full house.
>> Yeah, it looks like it. It's packed.
So Andrew, we've moved beyond asking
whether physical AI is possible. What's
changed over the past 18 to 24 months
that makes this the moment when it's
finally beginning to scale commercially?
Finally.
>> Finally. Yeah. See, finally is the key
word here. So um I would assume almost
every speaker that's talking today has
spent 10 years plus working in this
space.
This hasn't just been an overnight
success for basically any of us. I
started path in uh 2018, but really I
started in 2014 doing my PhD in legged
robotics. So, it's been 12 years. 12
years of grinding.
>> You're an OG. An OJ.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, what's changed? So, what
what do I think has really changed in
the last 18 to 24 months? There's
probably three things. So, top thing is
just notice that this market is real and
that this is possible. So, OpenAI and
Tropic have truly shown what AI can do
and where that ceiling can go. So, the
belief that this is real. Again, over a
decade ago is when we did the DARPA
challenge and legged robotics in the
United States. A decade ago and it went
extremely poorly. It's taken this much
time to really get to this point. So,
one, I think there's a revitalized
belief that we can get there. two,
there's energy, time, and people really
going into this. Obviously, this room is
a a good catalyst for what the rest of
the world is looking like in terms of
putting their energy into it. And then
I'd say three, compute. Fact that we all
have access to actual compute at this
point at at scale is really really
accelerating the development. And then
finally, the most important thing is the
flywheel of data. I'm sure you're going
to hear about data all the time at this
conference, but it is the most vital
piece of this entire puzzle. To build a
foundation model, you need a foundation
data set. To get a foundational data
set, you need to collect data at mass.
And a lot of groups are doing it through
a lot of different techniques. But the
fact that a lot of us have started to do
deployments, get robots into the field,
and actually turn on that flywheel for
continuous data collection, continuous
learning. This is a really good early
inflection point around we are starting
to see early scale, but what we're going
to see over the next three to five years
is going to be mindbending.
>> So, what what inning do you think we're
in right now? Do you think we're still
in the first inning?
>> Oh, definitely definitely definitely
first.
>> 1.5,
>> maybe first batter still. This is where
we're at. And so, again, as we get deep
into this, it's going to be incredible
to see.
>> So, as you mentioned, Path was founded
in 2018, right? So, you've been doing
this for years. You've been, you know,
you spent years deploying physical AI in
real manufacturing environments. What
have those deployments taught you about
what it actually takes to move from
prototype to commercialization and
ultimately to happy customers at scale?
>> Yeah, happy customers.
That's a that's a really hard thing to
do in robotics, just to be totally
frank. You see this time and time again
where you hear a big name and you see
that they're delivering to you a Fortune
10 customer and then you see that their
robots are no longer deployed or they're
left at one robot or they're left at a
handful and they're not scaling. Getting
to a happy customer is probably one of
the hardest thing in robotics. robotics,
tech stack, hardware, software, AI, all
of those things matter. But the final
thing at the end is can it actually
deliver value to a customer and is that
value something that you can tangibly
measure, tangibly show, and get
conviction to scale past it. So a lot of
people ask me, I might jump to a later
question, ask me why I didn't do general
purpose. Why did I not go after the
robot and the brain that can do
everything?
mainly because we want to first start
and focus on how do we make the
economics truly work? How do we make
customers happy so that they're buying
more, buying more consistently? I can
tell you in the last 15 months, PATH's
revenue has 15xed and our net revenue
retention is over 200%. So all of our
customers in the last 15 months have
doubled their bet on us at least. And
why they're doing that is because we
started in an industry where there is
real pain. Not an industry where it's a
nice to have. Not an industry where
maybe I want it. It's an industry where
if I don't have this, my company may
die.
Starting there with a customer painoint
is ultimately the way to make the
economics work for you which is
ultimately the way that you can actually
funnel and fuel growth through your own
business which is where we all have to
get in the end. So for us it's a big
reason to start and focus on customers
with true painpoint that are going to be
pulling. When we think about the data
flywheel and everybody is forecasting in
their in their decks that the last the
the vast majority of their data is going
to come from customers. The only way
that is true is if the customer is happy
enough to keep it and scale it. If
you're going to have a data farm and
expect that to cover your entirety and
totality of data, you're going to be
fundraising tens of billions of dollars
on repeat. It's not possible. You have
to get the flywheel going from the
customers. You have to start with a pain
point where they're pulling so you can
deliver it and it can be a little rocky,
but they're there for it for the long
term. So that flywheel kicks off and
they see the progression from day one is
the worst day ever. Year two is much
better. Year three, it's at the point
where they're extremely happy and they
want to buy this at scale.
>> Can we can we kind of drill deeper? So
across industries like heavy
fabrication,
energy, you know, ship building and
defense, what common pain points are
your customers trying to solve? And why
do you think physical AI is uniquely
suited to address these pain points?
>> Yeah. So we go after energy, AI, data uh
and uh defense. Those are three major
verticals. Why? Every single one of
those vertical has an extreme demand.
There is going to be $3 trillion spent
in the next 5 years in just those three
in the United States.
That is causing a huge demand of
products needing to be produced.
Ultimately then our customer has this
backlog. They have the buying signal.
They have the demand that they need.
It's time to go build. But they can't.
They physically do not have the labor to
actually build. It recently came out.
They asked the ship builder, if you were
given$10 billion dollars and just
given$10 billion, could you hit your
demand schedule? Could you hit your
capacity plan? They said no. $10 billion
hires every welder possible and that's
still not enough. So they physically
have this extreme pain point and they
have this need a need for labor right
now. And that's what we're seeing across
all three. They have the demand. They
have the capital. What they don't have
is the production. What they don't have
is the labor. They need a way to augment
it.
>> I'll even go into one use case really
quick. Okay.
>> All right. So, one use case on this. So,
like this is a real case, a real
customer of ours in Canada.
>> They make um skids for data centers. So,
data centers are becoming much more
modular, which means there's a platform,
there's a housing, there's a frame.
Their skid prior to PATH took 150 man-h
hours of welding.
They would have had to 10x their
workforce to make their production needs
happen. Instead, they went to physical
AI. They went to uh intelligent robotics
that could be taking on this hard job.
They moved their manual hours from 150
down to 9. 91% savings. And that was the
exact metric they would need at 10x to
hit their capacity and that's what we
were able to deliver to them.
>> Wow, that's amazing. Um, you know, as as
investors evaluate this category, I'm
just kind of curious like what
distinguishes companies that are
building exciting technology from
companies that are really building
durable, longlasting platforms.
>> Yeah.
It's a good question. Um,
it's tough in robotics.
It takes a long time to get to a durable
platform. Straight up. It just takes
time. So, almost everybody and probably
most of the speakers today, they're
going to be talking about the demo.
They're going to be talking about
something exciting. They're going to be
talking about the vision as they need to
point somewhere and they need to give
themselves time to get to durability.
In my opinion, having the best model is
just one piece of it. Really
understanding your customers pain
points. How is the system going to show
up every day? How are you going to
support this system? And how does it
solve the actual issue at hand for them?
In the end, robots is going to be a
services business. And you have to be
incredible at service to actually
deliver on that. You don't get to just
be great at tech. You don't just be
great at collecting data and training a
model. You have to be in the weeds with
your customers every single day. And so
I think that I think you're going to see
a lot of the shift from the conversation
which still today early innings. It's
about the vision. It's about general.
It's about going where we can or our
imagination can take us two years, three
years from four years from now. It's
going to be about delivering value.
That's where the conversation is going
to start shifting. And we're starting to
see that shift now. It's just still
early days and when people start to talk
about the value creation for customers
that's when I think we'll start to know
that durable companies are being built
in this space.
>> Where where are you kind of seeing the
most I guess push back or reticence from
your customers? I mean are there any
concerns around you know job
displacement or is it really that they
literally will not be able to produce on
time if they don't use path?
>> Yeah. To me like so our our 100% of our
conversations about production. We have
never had a single customer lay off a
laborer because of us. This is nothing
to do with cost savings. This is
everything to do with revenue growth,
production growth. That's the
conversations that we have with these
customers. Um, even so much a lot of our
customers are in manufacturing,
they give incentive bonuses to the shop
floor on a weekly or monthly basis. It's
about hitting quota. If you hit quota,
everybody gets a bonus.
Getting that and that was something that
was taught to us and then we've helped
ingrain that into our customers that
this is the way to do this. Doing that
has helped a ton of buyin for why the
robot should be there, why it's
ultimately helping keeping this c
company in business and also filling the
pockets with more money for the people
on the shop floor. So incentivizing
production on the floor shop floor and
having robots help accelerate that. We
have gotten a massive acceptance of our
bots on the shop floor. None of our
customers are the ones talk and none of
our customers laborers are the ones
talking about jobs being replaced by
robots. They're the ones talking about
jobs being created and companies being
accelerated by robots. So that's what we
talk about and that's what we hear all
the time. It's not the other way around.
So obviously you know everyone at
Machina today is very bullish optimistic
about the future of physical AI but what
do you think the industry still
underestimates
about building and scaling successful
you know successful uh physical AI
companies?
>> Yeah I think everyone's underestimating
the operational lift. The operational
lift is huge. Um truly deploying at
scale turning on continuous learning. I
mean even the hyper
even the extremely large model providers
are still trying to figure out how to do
continuous learning. This entire room is
betting on continuous learning.
Continuously able to collect data from
the customer, clean it, train it,
potentially fine-tune, post-train a
model, and then deliver it to that
specific bot and do that thousands, tous
thousands, hundred thousands of times
over until your model can be run without
post training. It's a huge operational
lift. And then even on the the dream
state the dream state where it's one
model that does everything flawlessly
with mo with no post training
that is going to be hard to get and that
is going to be really difficult to
actually see come to resolution. So if
you really to take a bet and you're
going to bet on anything, you're going
to bet on post training. And if you're
going to bet on post training, you
should be betting on MLOps and general
operational scale of how to collect,
clean, and do continuous learning at an
individual bot perspective. It's a huge
operational lift, but that is what we're
going to see truly deployed in the next
three to five years.
Um,
so I guess look looking ahead, you've
kind of answered this already, but where
do you think, you know, where do you
believe the greatest value in physical
AI will be created over the next 5
years? And are there additional
industries that you're thinking about
going into in addition to the three that
you guys are currently serving today?
>> Yeah, so for us, um, we see industrial
manufacturing and we want to help
provide solutions to all of it. um a
really exciting recent launch for us. So
we make a model, it's called Obsidian.
It gets delivered onto robots. It allows
us to be agnostic of robot and robot
type. And so for the past, you know,
seven, eight years, we've been
delivering on tra traditional arms, six
off, seven off arms with a little bit of
mobility, but really meant to be on
indoor manufacturing under a ceiling
covered by, you know, with power, easily
accessible parts that come to the robot.
Um, we recently launched our new
platform off of uh called Rove. It's
essentially our brain that's running
Boston Dynamics Spot. And at the end of
it, we've attached a welding torch and
given the system eyes, ears, and a brain
to think on the edge. This is enabling
us now to think past indoor
manufacturing and to think going to the
site. So going to the shipyard, onto a
ship, into a ship around a ship, going
to an actual data center site. Instead
of us just making parts indoor that was
shipped to a data center, we're now
physically going to walk robots to a
data center, we're going to help them
weld the the beams and the columns that
erect the entire facility. We're going
to help them weld the final HVAC lines,
the final piping that actually goes
around the entire facility. So, we see a
huge opportunity for robots to leave
indoors, to be unchained, and to go
outdoors. And we see legs as actually an
opportunity to get a lot of value. It's
been tough to make the argument for
where legs are going to be useful in
robots on indoor manufacturing. It just
has been.
It's really easy to make the argument
once you leave, once you go outside,
once you open the door, once you're on
rocky terrain, once you're on an
environment that's continuously changing
with stairs, with levels, it's a really
exciting opportunity. I think we're
excited to see what is going to come of
Legged Robotics in here in the near
future.
Very exciting. And with that, I think we
are out of time. Thanks, Andrew.
>> Thank you very much.